[Musique]
l'arrivée au pouvoir de la coalition
avenir québec avec une forte majorité 75
députés sur 125 est sans doute l'un des
événements politiques les plus marquants
de cette année avec des propositions
tranché françois legault a ouvert les
débats sur des questions délicates comme
les signes religieux l'immigration le
cannabis et deux mois et demi après son
élection nous avons rencontré monsieur
legault pour savoir où il en est sur les
signes religieux notamment le premier
ministre assoupli sa position
voici donc la première partie de cette
entrevue réalisée ce matin c'est le goût
bonjour vous êtes premier ministre
depuis près de trois mois
on vous sent plus détendu plus à l'aise
qu'est ce que ça a changé pour vous
c'est certain qu'avant le 1er octobre on
voulait pas perdre de temps pour essayer
de marquer des points convaincre la
population pour gagner le 1er octobre
quand on gagne on sait qu'on a 4 1
s'enlève du stress et je pense qu'on ne
devient plus calme
je pense aussi que la fonction amène
certaine sérénité en du moins la tac
avec nos adversaires on essaie plutôt de
rassembler donc c'est différent c'est un
pote du tout gênée de refuser de
l'énergie salle alors que nous on off
d'énergie pop qui très impliqué
compétitive c'est le métier aussi qu'ils
rendent parce que par exemple parler de
l'énergie salle de l'alberta c'était une
erreur non non je pense pas je pense que
le message devait clair on me demandait
pourquoi moi je demande à exporter plus
d'hydroélectricité dans le reste du
canada et pourquoi je refuse que le
reste du canada exporte plus de pétrole
au québec mais j'expliquais que nous
c'est d'énergie propre recette l'énergie
propre ou sale mais c'est factuel il
n'ya pas d'acceptabilité sociale au
québec faut bien qu'un autre verdict
pour un nouvel oléoduc qui traverserait
le québec franchement les yeux aucune
acceptabilité sociale au québec
est-ce que c'était pas une preuve
d'amour
de sensibilité à tous - surtout au
moment où les chiffres sur la
péréquation sortais c'était clair soit
quand même 13 milliards de péréquation
on comprend un peu la colère de
l'alberta non bon d'accord on à
déduction al interne puis moi j'ai bien
expliqué que je voulais pas donner de
leçon à l'alberta mais en même temps je
dois expliquer que moi je le dis depuis
longtemps que je peux satisfait de
l'économie du québec moi je suis gêné
qu'on reçoive 13 milliards par année de
péréquation parce qu'on est moins riche
que le reste du canada puis je vais tout
faire je pense une bonne équipe
économique pour créer la richesse peut
réduire cet écart là donc je suis pas
content de recevoir de la péréquation
mais en même temps fou je dise la vérité
les québécois ne veulent pas d'oléoducs
de pétrole au québec
vous voulez toujours baisser vos seuls
d'immigration qu'est ce que le
gouvernement fédéral vous dit à ce sujet
on soit 50000 immigrants par année à
40000 immigrants par année le québec
toutes proportions gardées vont
continuer de recevoir beaucoup plus
d'immigrants que les états unis ou que
la france par exemple c'est sûr que si
on se compare avec le reste qu'un donne
en soi - sont ce compact les autres pays
on a souhaité plus mais ce qui est
important c'est de dire quand on regarde
ce qui reste au québec se trouvent un
emploi
on a des problèmes d'intégration il y en
a beaucoup trop quittent le québec parce
qu'ils trouvent pas un emploi
intéressant beaucoup troupes sont au
chômage puis un problème si
d'apprentissage français l'année
dernière plus de la moitié des nouveaux
arrivants ne parlait pas français
et la majorité des adultes qui ne
parlait pas français ne suis jamais de
cours de français donc faut toujours
comprendre que ça sera fragile pour
toujours le français en amérique du nord
on est entouré d'une mer d'anglophones
donc l'intégration aux français nous on
veut ou si négocier avec ottawa pour
exiger la réussite d'un examen de
français avant de donner la citoyenneté
donc il ya des ajustements à faire
une fois qu'on aura fait ces ajustements
on pourra recommencer à augmenter le
nombre d'immigrants mme actuellement on
a dépassé notre capacité d'intégration
donc vous alliez les augmenter à partir
de quand aussi vite on va être capable
d'intégrer aussi vite on va pouvoir
augmenter le nombre donc mon objectif
c'est pas de réduire pour réduire ces de
réduire le temps d'avoir une meilleure
intégration pour ensuite recommencé à
augmenter donc à la fin de votre mandat
est ce qu'on va être revenir à la case
départ
bayon vos j'espère même peut-être plus
élevé que la case départ mais par contre
on va avoir beaucoup plus d'intégration
en emploi beaucoup plus d'intégration
aux français puis aussi s'assurer que
les gens connaissent nos valeurs
l'égalité homme femme la laïcité la
démocratie
il ya des inquiétudes il faut pas
regarder de haut les québécois qui ont
ces inquiétudes long le vus a eu des
dérapages en france des der
désunie donc faut être prudent s'assurer
là quand même qu'on mettre un cadre
ce qui se passe en france les jeunes et
jaune est ce que ça vous inquiète parce
qu'on est à l'abri d'une colère tout à
coup on n'est pas la population n'est
pas d'abri vous avez vu en france qui
est à l' us a commencé dans les régions
on a eu des gens qui trouvait qu'il y
avait beaucoup de taxes vous avez vu
pendant campagne électorale j'ai
beaucoup parlé de la classe moyenne qui
beaucoup travaillé fort mais qui a de la
difficulté à arriver à la fin du mois
donc c'est pour ça que déjà dans les
deux premières semaines on annonce une
mise à jour qui remettent d'argent dans
le portefeuille des familles dans le
portefeuille des années chantait mes
adversaires quand je parlais du
portefeuille des québécois qui est garde
des sceaux de haut
mais si on veut éviter des dérapages
faut être capable de remettre de
l'argent un portefeuille des québécois
donc ça change la façon de gouverner
quand on voit une colère comme celle là
dans la rue il ya des inquiétudes
il ya des inquiétudes sur le
portefeuille il ya des inquiétudes sur
l'intégration des immigrants faut pas
regarder ça de haut
c'est un pas dire qu'il faut avoir un
dérapage mais il faut être capable de
mettre un cadre et puis de bien
comprendre les préoccupations des
québécois puis moi c'est ce que j'essaie
de faire
puis mes ministres et députés je leur
dis régulièrement là soyez pas arrogant
rester proche des préoccupations des
québécois
les personnes auront la possibilité de
se relocaliser oui donc de tuer un autre
emploi c'est le souhaitent souhaite
religieux font le choix de ne plus est
cet emploi ce moment là ce sera leur
choix signes religieux
l'interdiction des signes religieux qui
s'appliquera non seulement aux juges aux
policiers gardiens de prison mais aussi
pour les enseignants
au lendemain d'élections geneviève
guilbault disait que les récalcitrants
perdront leur emploi
est ce que vous êtes d'accord toujours
avec votre nom est ce là dessus d'abord
ce qui est important de dire lorsque nos
propositions sont très raisonnables par
rapport par exemple la charte des
valeurs du parti québécois nous on dit
seulement les personnes en autorité donc
n'y a pas beaucoup de personnes
aujourd'hui parmi les juges gardiens de
prison
policiers et enseignants du primaire
secondaire différence entre les
enseignants et le reste la coercition la
côte et puis de louis oui mais une
enseignante qui a devant elle une petite
fille de 5 ans m6 se son modèle à la
petite fille donc c'est important qu'ils
aient neutralité qui a pas de message
ambigu sur l'égalité hommes-femmes donc
moi je pense qu'une enseignants à la
petite école est en situation d'autorité
donc bon est ce que les personnes qui
actuellement sont en poste pourrait
perdre leur emploi
je sais pas ce que je souhaite je
souhaite qu'on soit capable de voir si
on peut les replacer dans les bureaux
bon on va examiner différentes
possibilités spationautes objectif
droits acquis notre objectif c'est de
dire les prochains qui vont arriver là
soyons clairs au québec on exagère pas
on dit seulement les quelques personnes
qui sont à des postes en autorité
pourront pas porter de signes religieux
ya des gens qui pensent que c'est pour
toute la fonction publique c'est pas
dans la rue sur les lieux publics ça va
être permis donc on resterait beaucoup
plus par exemple qu'en france je pense
c'est raisonnable
je pense avoir rassuré les inquiétudes
de certains québécois mais revenons à ce
droit acquis donc les enseignants et
enseignantes qui porterait le voile par
exemple qui sont déjà en poste pourrait
demeurer en poste on vous écoutez moi je
vais aller coûte loges c'est pour
ouvrait la porte là je suis ouvert à
regarder le souhaiterait pas moi que
quelqu'un perde son emploi alors que
quand il ou elle a été embauchée ce cas
pas les mêmes règles
par contre que les règles soient claires
pour l'avenir mais en même temps on va
écouter ce que les gens venez nous dire
en commission parlementaire le projet de
loi va être déposé dès le mois de
février ou mars puis notre intention
c'est de l'adopter six mois de juin moi
je veux mettre ça derrière nous fait dix
ans qu'on débatte signes religieux
honnêtement j'aimerais mieux qu'on parle
d'éducation de santé d'économique parlé
de signes religieux en même temps
c'est nécessaire d'âge et on peut pour
continuer médecins autour du tapis une
précision dans le droit qui s'adresse
seulement aux enseignants ou bien c'est
pour tous les fonctionnaires si jamais
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de droits
acquis de prévu a pas de clause grands
pas mais ce que je dis c'est que je suis
ou va en tout cas des chauffeurs en
discuter vous croyez sincèrement
sérieusement que vous aller pour gagner
cette cause devant les tribunaux parce
que ça va être contestées écoutez on a
dès jeudi puis on pense même à le faire
dès le début d'utiliser la clause
dérogatoire donc la clause et les locaux
défendent des valeurs la spécificité du
québec donc utiliser la clause de
l'agathois ça va nous permettre pendant
cinq ans ne pas se retrouver devant les
tribunaux je pense qu'une grande
majorité de québécois qui supporte le
gouvernement j'ai eu un mandat le 1er
octobre un mandat clair aussi le 1er
octobre pour hausser l'âge légal de la
consommation de marijuana
même si la santé publique dit que ça va
pousser les jeunes vers le marché noir
même s'il ya beaucoup d'experts qui
disent pourquoi vous voulez absolument
aller de l'avant bon on a un médecin
lyonnais le cas demain qui est
spécialiste à saint-just scène auprès
des gens que j'ai rencontrés entre
autres les petits câbles qui me disent
ya un risque réel
lorsqu'un jeunes consomment du cannabis
de développer des problèmes graves de
santé mentale comme les schizophrènes
bien nettement même personnellement j'en
connais des jeunes à qui c'est arrivé
donc si je suis capable
en mettant l'âge légal à 21 ans de
convaincre des jeunes de ne pas aller
sur le marché légal
j'aurai atteint mon objectif moi c'est
ça ma priorité protéger jeunes sauf que
les jeunes
de 15 à 18 ans à 24 ans en consomment
déjà de la marijuana alors comment vous
allez et comment vous allez atteindre
votre cible comme ça parce que l'oeil
comme disait même le premier ministre
trudeau où vous allez les envoyer chez
les aides ils vont continuer d'en
consommer et de moins bonne qualité en
plus pour un joueur pour il ya des
jeunes aussi qui consomment de la
cocaïne qui toutes sortes de drogues
mais c'est pas une raison pour légaliser
tout le m'a donné faut envoyer un
message que c'est dangereux et
idéalement on veut pas que les gens
consomment même avant 25,1 parce qu'il
ya des risques et puis je les ai vus
comme ancien ministre de l'éducation
lors autour des promesses électorales
que vous voulez respecter non moi c'est
vraiment quelque chose le qui me touche
profondément
je veux envoyer un message clair s'il
vous plaît les jeunes ne consommait pas
de cannabis c'est dangereux attendait au
moins à 25
environnement oui vous avez oublié ça en
campagne électorale et la juste après
vous avez dit bon je ne peux pas ignorer
ce défi l'urgence climatique et
continuer de regarder mes deux fils dans
les yeux ça va être quoi votre priorité
concrètement là pour l'environnement
pour l'environnement la priorité c'est
le transport il faut arrêter les grands
discours on a vu que les chiffres qui
sont sortis pour le mans donne monsieur
couillard on en profite c'est réduire
les ges au contraire ils ont augmenté
par rapport aux autres provinces le
québec est déjà chaud est important de
répéter quand on regarde les ges par
habitant
on est le meilleur élève on est la
province qui le plus bas grâce à
l'hydroélectricité trop grâce à
l'hydroélectricité qu'on aimerait
exporter chez nos voisins pour les aider
puisse aider parce qu'on est sur la même
planète
mais aujourd'hui ou transports
concrètement d'abord transports en
commun la ligne bleue on va commencer à
construire un train moins dans l'est de
clips de montréal on voyait les le r
un train électrique on voit même le
prolonger le tramway à québec on va
aller de l'avant et donc du transport en
commun transport en commun ensuite
véhicule électrique ça ça veut dire des
autos électriques des camions
électriques des autobus électriques
ça prend des routes pour faire circuler
des autos électriques donc je comprends
qu'il ya des gens qui disent faut plus
avoir de route faut juste avoir du
transport en commun
c'est mal connaître le québec quand on
s'en va par exemple dans chaudière
appalaches
mais il n'y a pas de volume suffisant
pour avoir du transport en commun pour
tout le monde donc d'encourager le
transport électrique notamment au niveau
économique
c'est bon pour le québec parce que si on
réduit notre consommation de pétrole
qu'on importe mais qu on augmente notre
consommation d'électricité où on a des
surplus on y gagne 1 aussi
économiquement donc le travail en
transport ça va être ma priorité
messi a des gros projet avec beaucoup
d'emplois qui viennent avec
est-ce que vous allez être prêt à aller
à les bloquer si jamais le coût
environnemental est trop élevé tout est
une question d'équilibré
mais je vous rappelle la cimenterie
mécanisme en gaspésie qui polluent pour
l'équivalent de 500 mille voitures
le pq tpo le parti libéral de pau et la
cac et à cons donc faut aussi et m'a
donné sortie des dix copies passer à
l'action faut avoir un équilibre
moi je pense que pour 200 emplois de sa
vie comme si difficile aux conseils des
minima gines quand il ya des projets
économiques
non ça prend six projets lopy la
ministre votre ministre l'environnement
va être capable de se tenir depuis de
dire non oui absolument faut avoir un
équilibre et l'appuyer
ça veut pas dire qu'on veut plus faire
de projets de développement économie
d'avoir des usines avec des robots qui
émettent moins de gs ge c'est possible
de le faire l'intelligence artificielle
les technologies de l'information il ya
beaucoup de domaines dans lesquels on
peut se développer
cinq cents d'impact négatif sur les gs
une dernière question sur la sphère
gilbert rozon parce qu'évidemment ça
préoccupe beaucoup de gens ça fait
beaucoup réagir un dossier retenu sur 14
par le directeur des poursuites
criminelles et pénales est ce qu'il ya
un problème selon vous dans le
traitement des dossiers d'agressions
sexuelles est bon d'abord je vais être
plus d'un dossier de monsieur rauzan
c'est devant les tribunaux où il ya une
accusation donc je peux commenter ce
dossier là par contre de façon générale
mois samic de voir des personnes qui
hésitent à dénoncer le message doit être
clair tout sauf le silence dénoncé puis
il faut regarder si les femmes qui
disent mais pourquoi et au moins ça soit
plus facile bon puis moi je suis ou 20
je l'entendais véronique hivon dit
est-ce que possibilité d'avoir un tacot
peut-être spéciale qui est pas le même
que pour les eaux innacor un tribune en
moi schumacher
en même temps faut comprendre qu'une
partie qui est de juridiction fédérale
il ya une partie aussi qu'il fait partie
de notre droit quelqu'un est présumé
n'ont pas jusqu'à preuve du contraire
hors de tout doute raisonnable on veut
ton change et ça une bonne discussion à
y avoir mais faut être prudent même
envoyé un message très clair là les
femmes entre autres qui ont subi des
agressions du harcèlement sexuel doivent
dénoncer pour doit faciliter cette
possibilité dans alors dans un an on
peut refaire ce bilan si vous voulez
bien on va créer une habitude une
nouvelle habitude
si vous aviez une chose que vous
aimeriez avoir accompli d'ici un an
qu'est ce que ce serait en terminant le
dépistage auprès des enfants qui ont des
difficultés d'apprentissage donc
commencé à dépister dès l'âge de 3 ans
puis commence à donner des services au
plus tard à l'âge de 4 ans que ce soit
dans une garderie que ce soit dans une
maternelle 4 ans mais être capable de
donner des services aux enfants on parle
de plus de 6%
des enfants qui ont étudié
l'apprentissage donc plus
d'orthophonistes plus d'autos pédagogues
des classes plus petites
si on ceux qui utilisent enfants là on
va voir nos taux de diplomation de matip
c'est bon pour la société
on va voir un bout de fait c'est la
priorité
je vous souhaite de très joyeuses fêtes
merci à vous si madame guen peau merci
beaucoup